Hallo Bushido keine Frage ich bisher
habe ich keine
hat der Start geklappt auch muss man
selber Fahrradtechnik an damit man daher
werde Texte schreiben kann
meine Frage an sie gewesen bist du
wirklich witzig und bissig witzig
um Damen Jahr was heißt es wirklich
kriminelle so ich habe glaube ich hab
auch schon mal Sachen gemacht die
verboten sind ich habe
Verkehrspsychologen weil ich Prozent
chronische rote Ampel Fahrer bin
das reicht auch schon für Leute um zu
sagen dass man Klien deutschen
kriminelles ansonsten mit Reibe ich kein
Menschenhandel und so auch Prozent wenn
ich in Paris dazu nicht schädlich
um mögliche Abriss der Schutz gelte
weder von Prozent Prozent deutsche
Bäckerei noch von Toshiba nahe legen
und ansonsten würde man andererseits
auch nicht kriminell um im Endeffekt
wäre auch Versuche ich natürlich wer
nicht als Kindler zur Kreuzung weil man
bei Sachen erwischt wird und wir so ich
wird dann einfach mal so an Säure
Genießer schweigt und solange man nicht
erwischt wird es wohl Stimmen